البعض كان على بعد خطوات من كارثه انفجار
الغواصه تايتن والبعض الاخر كان اكثر حظا
وحرصا فالخوف ليس جبنا دائما بل قد يكون
طوق النجاه
ركاب سابقون
لتايتنبه بداخلها فشركه اوشنجيتا الملكه
للغواصه قامت بين عامي 2021
و2022 ببعثتين استكشافيتين الى حطام
تايتنك قبل تحطم تايتن في الرحله الثالثه
اتفق جميع من خاضوا التجارب السابقه على
انما مروا به كان مخيفا ومثيرا للقلق
في اللحظه التي بدانا فيها اختبار الغوص
بدات الامور تسير بشكل خاطئ
المشاكل التي عانت منها غواصه تايتن كانت
مفصليه فهي مشاكل تتعلق بالسلامه فحسب
شهادات الركاب فانها كانت تهوي بشكل غير
منتظم كما ان التحكم المطلق بالدخول
والخروج للغواصه يتم فقط من الخارج ومن
بداخلها ينتظر مكبل اليدين والحركه
بداخلها مقيده فلا وقوف ولا انحناء فقط
الجلوس طيله الرحله
والابرز ادوات اتصال ضعيفه فقد الاتصال
بها مرات عده اضافه الى وسائل التحكم
ركيكه جعلت التحكم بقياده الغواصه اشبه ما
يكون بسياره تقاد بحاله عدم توازن
عندما لمست الغواصه قع المحيط توقف كل شيء
عن العمل
من نفذ من الموت داخل تايتن تجرعه بصوره
غير مباشره فالشركه المشغله للغواصه كانت
تشترط التوقيع على تعهد باخلاء المسؤوليه
يذكر مرارا بان الوفاه في سبيل استكشاف
المحيطات امر متوقع
الشركه تلزم الركاب بالتوقيع على وثائق
للاعفاءات من اي مسؤوليه عقليه او في حاله
الوفاه
تجارب سابقه لم تروى الا بعد ان راح ضحيه
الغواصه تايتنك خمسه اشخاص ابرزهم صاحب
الشركه المشغله لها روان حمزه العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات